would you rather be bitten by a venomous
snake or touch a poisonous frog wait
what's the difference between poison and
venom anyway let's say you have the
misfortune to be bitten by a venomous
rattlesnake when it bites you the snake
will eject venom from little sacs behind
its eyes through its hollow fangs and
into your flesh that venom will then
travel through your bloodstream all over
your body in most cases snake venom
contains neurotoxins proteins that can
do all sorts of nasty stuff like make
your muscles fire and controllably burst
your blood cells and make you go
completely numb but you might get lucky
snakes don't always decide you're worth
wasting venom on in fact between 20 and
80 percent of snake bites are so called
dry bites where the snake is just trying
to send the message without actually
killing you you see venom takes energy
and resources for the snake to make and
they don't want to waste it on a warning
shot when it comes to poison on the
other hand there's no warning shot if
you pick up a poisonous dart frog to
admire its beautiful colors you've
already gotten deadly poison all over
your hands as it seeps into your skin
and travels through your blood the
poison starts to interfere with your
nerves preventing your muscles from
attracting if the frogs poison reaches
your heart it can cause it to stop the
distinction between venom and poison is
purely in the method of delivery poison
has to be inhaled ingested or absorbed
and venom has to be injected into a
wound chemically Venom's and poisons are
both considered toxins so a snake bite
is venomous a poison dart frog is
poisonous brown recluse spiders are
venomous puffer fish are poisonous and
some compounds can be poisons in one
animal and Venom's another tetrodotoxin
a chemical ten thousand times more toxic
than cyanide is found in pufferfish
where it makes them poisonous it's also
found in the deadly blue ringed octopus
where it's a venom delivered by bite
some animals can even be both poisonous
and venomous take the Asian tiger snake
for example not only does it have venom
in its fangs but it also absorbs the
toxins from the poisonous toads it eats
and then secretes those toxins from
special glands on its neck rendering it
poisonous to scientists are constantly
finding new animals that employ toxins
in weird interesting ways recently
researchers discovered the very first
venomous crustacean out of 70,000
species of crustaceans only this one
little remipede is venomous smelly no
neck tease
Tolu menses has figured out how to
create a cocktail of toxins that it
delivers through its tiny fangs
scientists aren't totally sure how this
venom works yet but they think that it
causes the unwitting victims neurons to
fire over and over and over again until
it becomes paralyzed
then the little remipede closes in
dissolving away the exoskeleton of its
prey and sucking out the juices but
poisons and Venom's aren't always all
bad for thousands of years humans have
looked for ways to harness the power of
these toxic compounds for good today we
have all sorts of medicines that come
from toxins the poison from cone snails
is used as a painkiller many poisonous
plants have been used to treat
everything from malaria to irregular
heartbeats and scorpion venom might one
day be used to treat heart disease so
what do you do if something bites or
poisons you don't try any of the things
you've seen on the internet or in movies
don't try to capture and kill the animal
that bit you and don't use a tourniquet
or knife on your wound most importantly
don't panic stay calm and seek medical
attention treatment will mostly depend
on what species you encountered but if
you forget the distinction between
poison and venom and tell the paramedics
that you were poisoned by a Viper
they'll probably forgive you and treat
you anyway
you